in his twelfth season as general manager
of the Houston Rockets his rockets will
be kicking off the second half of the
season tonight on TNT in the second half
of their doubleheader against the Los
Angeles Lakers with James Harden putting
his 30 plus points per game streak on
the line at 31 and potentially counting
it is general more on the show good to
see you sir thanks for having me I
appreciate it let's get him down with
dealt with Harden because a harden told
Rachel Nichols during the break that he
had to do what he's done right now would
you agree with that assessment I would
yeah no he saved our season we've had I
think tonight's the first time ever
starting lineup in months so we're
pretty we're pretty excited I have never
seen a player have to apologize for for
winning and for scoring against which I
don't remember Michael Jordan saying hey
sorry sorry for scoring 40 tonight so
it's been a real strange ride I mean
we've been winning at a really high clip
while he's been on this run and really
saved our season as you know Chris is
out Clint is out all our guys have been
on so it's if I'm not mistaken Brock
would correct me if I'm wrong didn't
Kobe at one point sitting next to Tracy
McGrady with Rachel Nichols say that
it's not sustainable in the playoffs
that hardens play isn't that correct
well certainly what a champion should
win a championship would you agree with
that yeah I would say like the that way
of XOR that player can if you do that it
doesn't win a championship is the
easiest bet to make in sports like only
one team wins so I get really bothered
by people saying this this can't win or
that can't win well the odds are pretty
good you're gonna be right and on top of
it you can't win that way until you do
so there was the thought that you can't
play like Golden State and win you can't
shoot threes well we haven't heard about
that in a while heavily so we're gonna
play whatever is the best way to help us
win games and we think it can win in the
playoffs so that everybody's back to me
everybody's fresh everybody's good our
whole starting here was bad we got maybe
some bench guys out but whole starters
are back okay
so against playoff LeBron so a big one
it's gonna be a big one LeBron says he's
starting his playoff mode early he is
yes yeah so I you know he's he's amazing
so you know that
actually is uh it should be a great game
okay so where do you watch the game from
where are you you the stands for this
one I do better on road games home games
I actually have more trouble I'll watch
in the back like I know you have your
sanctum where you watch football we have
a similar in Houston you do yeah yeah
it's not quite as nice as you guys at
the first rate here but we got a nice
room alright so before we return to your
your team I want to get into the topic
du jour today that it does involve Zion
Williamson whose shoe exploded on him
last night now I know were you a Duke
practice this past week I I wasn't do
practice right right after the Charlotte
all-star game okay coach Tchaikovsky was
very kind to invite myself to the
practice and I was able to watch it's an
impressive thing I mean he's he's a
legend for a reason so what do you see
what do you glean from something like
that is it yeah I mean we can't get too
close so I'm not you know I'm not
allowed to talk to you the prospect so
it's just watching I did talk to Coach K
after but yeah you actually learn a lot
in practice habits that was a very
intense practice they're preparing for
their most important game of the year so
I thought it was a great one to go to so
how do you know Mike I mean how long
have you known Coach K so some of our
staff knows him away better like coach
D'Antoni coach with them in USA
basketball and you know I know they've
traded ideas a lot gerson roses who's on
the USA staff on the scouting and
operations side so we we have a tight
relationship with Coach K and then your
NBA daryl morey shot Rockets general
manager I'm fascinated by what the rules
are
so you are you are bound by the NBA to
know you're not allowed to talk to the
kids at all I can't no I can't talk to
any of the players until they declare
themselves eligible for the draft which
happens which happens later and I can't
even talk about them either I cannot
hear you may not talk about that I can't
I can't say anything about any any
player in college right now I don't want
to get you in any trouble then so then
let me ask a general question if a
player decides to not play anymore
midseason
don't play in the NCAA tournament
because let's say I don't know a shoe
explodes on them on national television
we're getting close to the line like
what if what if a player just in general
decides to look I don't want to put my
body at risk in the same way we're
seeing a lot of college football players
do not playing their final ballgame how
does that affect your evaluation of this
player oh it wouldn't change my evaluate
in terms of like the player we're just
looking at their talent we're looking at
what they can do so what they choose to
do where they choose to play some
players have played overseas you know to
get paid some players go to college some
players even sit out the whole year like
enes kanter did years ago so that none
of that really affects how mba teams
look at these players we look you know
you know Kyrie Irving got hurt and like
and he you know he only played like five
games at Duke or something like that so
and he went I believe one so I think so
I think yeah I think it's not a huge
deal for MBA evaluators we look at the
talent mostly what about the heart they
want to wouldn't that be a question that
you would have of somebody that decides
to no longer put their body on the line
because they know it would cost them
potentially dollars and cents I think
like things like love of the game
driving hard are super important but
when we're talking about very elite
talents you know you know take a Joel
embiid years ago where he he didn't play
many games at Kansas those players
always go high in the draft no matter
elite talents are gonna go high no
matter what on those other factors now
again I don't want to get you to too
close to the fire here
but those players that you're mentioning
didn't play because they were not
physically able to play this is an
exception I think he was ineligible so
that's what I'm saying is that you know
what if somebody just decides to say I'm
healthy but I don't want to play anymore
because I don't want to hurt myself that
would not be an effective elementally
for me / I don't know how
other teams literally talents it
wouldn't it wouldn't affect me if you're
farther down like we generally picked in
the second round or late in the first
that's when those factors start to come
into play daryl morey here on the Rich
Eisen show and obviously there are some
elite talents that don't even need to go
to college so where do you stand on the
one and done rule as it currently
applies Darrell that's the because I
always have to remember um I I mean I
can just talk in general I really
believe in players like player
empowerment and I know that's been a
topic of debate both good and bad but I
think you know the players are the
talents we're here to facilitate that
and that's been a key edge at the
Houston Rockets you know all the all the
stars want to play with us because we
create an environment for them basically
okay so you don't have a philosophy one
way or another whether you think a kid
should come out of high school and play
for the Houston Rockets right away or is
that something you can't yeah I'm
worried I can't remember all the rules
but I would say you know we would want I
personally would want players in the NBA
as quickly as possible let's lose okay
all right Daryl Morey Houston Rockets
general manager here on the Rich Eisen
show last we spoke
it was first blush after LeBron James
had said something publicly about
Anthony Davis and how amazing it would
be and I asked you if you thought that
was tampering and your response was you
know you don't care if a player talks
about your other players right why yeah
I think commissioners address that
players are allowed to say whatever they
want about other players so yeah I mean
I the tampering rules I think overall
whether it be for players executives or
whatever I think they're selectively
enforced and basically unenforceable so
I would be for not having them at all at
all yeah I know I mean that's that's not
a majority of billion that you'd be able
to talk about any player in the NBA
right now but if yeah for me that would
be a preferred option it just would make
it more it would make everything above
the board you know that happens in those
interesting so like what if somebody
another general manager says man Harden
would be great on this team you wouldn't
have a problem with yeah I think if
you're not secure enough to say I've
created an environment
where this guy wants to be then I then I
think that's that's that's the your
problem not someone else's problem I
like that okay so what I'm curious to
know what you think cuz all of us here
in the media we fill our time talking
about what's what was gonna happen at
the trade deadline and what's gonna
happen at free agency because we're all
thinking who's gonna put the team
together to beat the Warriors now you
obviously general manager feel you have
already done something like that yeah I
mean we were there I mean we had over
50% championship odds at one point last
year there's no trophy for that
unfortunately unfortunately yeah but we
were there and we haven't played that
well to say we're championship quality
this year we're gonna have to prove that
as we're healthy down the stretch but we
do feel like we can be better than last
year going into the playoffs with the
talent we have now well and obviously
health has a lot to do with that
but the reason why I bring all of this
up is so many people in the media when
they see a trade like the Knicks did
opening up max spots that we are
assuming that players have already made
a decision on their free agency
destinations and have somehow signaled
it do you think players who are free
agents this July or any July by
midseason have already made a decision
sometimes I would say most of the time
they they might have Inklings they might
have told their agents you know here's a
few places I want to go but you can't
really sign them to paper until later so
there's no guarantees my sense is the
teams that open up cap room they're not
just looking at one player they're
looking at hey we've got you know some
good chance for this play or some you
know reasonable chance for this guy
maybe these four less likely but we
still have some chance so overall it's a
good move to open up room no I'm sure it
is but do you think that players have
already decided do you think that that
players know now it doesn't matter what
happens between now and then cuz we're
all assuming that guys are wanting to
create a new spot for their own unquote
legacy I'm wondering what somebody
really is involved in in general matter
I would say it's never a hundred percent
like I've had players who you know are
very likely to go to a certain team and
they might they might see something on
Twitter and it might affect how they
view think I mean it it's not over till
it's over and I think the idea that
they've generally already said a hundred
percent I know what I'm doing is almost
always not true at this time yeah I know
so many people think that you know again
other players in the NBA I don't want to
say their name yeah but we know where
they are that they're already there
they're either a gone or B not coming
back to that spot but definitely going
somewhere here that other it's kind of
crazy it's all probabilities I do think
you know those probabilities shift and
players might have a sense hey I want to
leave or I don't but there's never a
hundred percent there's always that
meeting where you make your case almost
always happens there are times when the
player doesn't have a meeting or
whatever but generally there's always at
least a moment where you have a chance
to sort of make your petty get you got
it you shoot your shot you'll know right
yes exactly as the kids a few minutes
left with daryl morey kind enough to
join us here on the day that his Rockets
take on the Lakers here in Los Angeles
how how active were you before the trade
deadline
we're active all year I mean we're our
philosophy is like we're trying to
assemble a championship teams around
James and Chris and we're gonna do
anything
we're always aggressive we're gonna
trade off future for present because we
believe our time is now so we have those
conversations constantly and all the
time so it's interesting you're you're
willing to trade future for present
right now ya know I think when you're in
a window of the players greatest Harden
who I think is gonna go down as one of
the all-time great offensive players if
he's not there already you've got a
you've got to go for it why do you think
he has had to apologize for his
Drake Daryl I I think because of coach
Dan Tony and him and the the way we play
is different just like you know Charles
Barkley was criticizing Golden State you
can't win by shooting threes or whatever
whenever you're doing something
different
people are gonna say you know that can't
work right you know they they fear
change they fear the different and I
think James said it himself when it's
former players who are not liking the
style but that happens all the time I
get down that he gets down because the
weight the way we play for sure can win
and we showed it last year so when you
say you get what do you mean by you get
down when he gets down yeah I mean he
had an interview at all-star where he
was like almost apologizing for having
to carry us on his back during this
period and I think it should be
celebrated because he's got 31 in a row
right now
I mean it's amazing yeah I'm actually
starting to like the beard so I grew the
beard when when he started scoring 30 so
is that right yeah how long do you think
I had to trim it though I don't know how
he does it like the hairs started going
everywhere so I don't know how he does
it
either it's just it's it's an impressive
it's the next situation we teeny on your
staff he's got that James Harden mere
mortals can't keep up with voting habits
of NBA players right now that you were
all healthy though you don't need them
to carry on right well that would be the
idea the ideas have a more diversified
attack but for people to have tried to
tear down him carrying us and getting us
to this point where we're positioned to
have another great playoff run I think
is it was pretty frustrating how do you
how do you last one for you on this
subject
yeah how do you do you compare yourself
to Golden State I mean when you hear
Steve Kerr say boogie cousins no longer
is gonna have a mean a minute ceiling I
mean are you tracking all of this yeah I
mean they're they're the best team they
should have won four in a row they've
won three of the last four you know
they're the standard so we always
compare ourselves to them okay and
you're not you don't make any bones
about it no I mean I think Oklahoma
City's terrific Denver's terrific this
year
there's some great teams in the East so
we got a knock off a lot of others but
they're there the champ for a reason I
mean that's the team almost for sure we
have to beat to win the title okay and
also we we we could not help but notice
do you have the bleacher report to tweet
that the Darrel responded to can we put
that up on the screen right here after
Ray Allen lit it up in the celebrity
game bleacher report said someone give
Jesus shuttle Shuttlesworth attend a you
retweeted it we are in if if he's yeah
he's my white whale since he walked away
from the game he's acted like he might
come back through his agent many times
we chased him down at a golf course once
what do you mean he's famously hard to
reach he his own agent that can't
communicate with him half the time
and so we've I've been chasing him for a
while he's perfect for our system he
keeps himself in unbelievable shape so
people thought that was a joke that is
not a joke Ray Allen I will sign I will
sign Ray Allen to attend a tomorrow or
today if he if he says he's in and
probably a bigger contract actually but
for sure the 10 day is easy well I mean
the cameras right there yeah just in
case Ray's out there you want to go
ahead and address it right there Ray
Allen you know we've been obsessively
chasing you for years we think you're
perfect for our system come to the he's
come to the Houston Rockets win another
championship it's time okay they go what
do you mean you chased him and of course
he he wouldn't he wouldn't call his
agent back and we wanted to sign him
during free agency this was probably two
years ago maybe three and he's like
maybe your only shot he's at this
charity golf event just donate and try
and get him and I couldn't make it but
we sent one of our staff there to try
and chase some town and not didn't get
it didn't get it couldn't get to him
couldn't get to him on a golf course no
no so this is all we do I obsess avais
players and sometimes sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't so that's why
you've been at it for 12 some percentage
of stalking works actually
when it comes to getting the play we get
that well completely all out there all
right so good luck to you man moving
forward here in your pursuit to bring a
championship to the city of Houston
thanks anytime anytime daryl morey
follow him on instagram daryl morey and
twitter @d Mori and he's got the Lakers
tonight good to see you sir thank you
thank you but the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience